i heard an interesting story
uh with henry cejudo talking about you
and doing the frog
down oh yeah the toad is is the toad the
same thing as dmt or is it
completely different it's totally
different um
it just takes you to another dimension
of life that we never experienced before
you know you realize that this is once
you do some um
i don't know whatever you talk
alternative medicine like the toad the
scorpion the lizard tail
the white cobra do that stuff and
it trusts me you you change your
perspective on you
yeah in life you never be the same again
man yeah it's crazy but it's all i mean
is all that stuff vastly different like
dmt trip versus uh the toad trip
was kind of the same it's the same but
it's
the toad is another animal the toad is
where you um
i won't say you see it but you feel it
so much that you do it appears to you
yeah you know your ancestors
your ego death you experience ego death
and that's very scary
yeah you know like that man hey imagine
this imagine everybody
in the world knowing your deepest
secrets you wouldn't want them to know
if they knew they would look at you
different
and then you have the feeling that
everyone knows everything about you
and it's scary and that's just scary man
it's just so
trip it's just you see your ancestors
you may see some
great grandparents you might see some
answers you never even met before and
it's just nuts man how long does that
trip last for
listen only 20 minutes but you're gonna
get like a hundred thousand years of
experience
that sounds about right i got it time
doesn't exist dude
nothing oh that's crazy
to be in that dimension where nothing
exists and
yeah everything that you love doesn't
even exist you forgot that
and that means and that tells me that um
when we do die
that um we can't go to the to the great
universe and say hey
it was those guys fought that did that
it would be you and him
all everything that you ever love you
will forget about it you won't even know
you have a wife a kid
a mother that you have to take care of
you just forget about them
and then you come out the first thing
you think hey where's my family where's
your school you know you you know you
did something that never been done to
you before
you're having hallucinations like that
when you were tripping
ah i had a lot of hallucinations man but
it didn't
no listen i was on cocaine when i first
did it
that coke that's the one when that hit
me man that cocaine
didn't even exist cocaine it was uh well
i
i that stopped me from doing drug drugs
because after doing that all that [ __ ]
was
[ __ ] weak to me yeah this is in my
mind this is a real drug
this is a real drug it doesn't it kills
you you get all those other drugs that
inflate your ego with deadly liquor
cocaine
all that stuff that um that's the
deli no good for your health this is
also
something that kills the ego but enhance
the body in the brain
it probably keeps you out of jail oh
listen
you know let's imagine the whole world
did this yeah nobody will ever have a
fight with nobody everybody
you see through the you see the beauty
in life you see
it's just inconceivable i can't even
articulate it
yeah it's so beautiful
yeah dude